Kong Skull Island is the second film in
the now official monster verse following
2014's Godzilla
we now have yet another property trying
to be Marvel it's true in this film we
have a group of people some scientists
some soldiers who are set to investigate
an uncharted island that has been found
known as Skull Island and of course when
they get there there's a whole lot of
monsters and a big giant ape also known
as Kong and john c reilly so this is
bound to be great guys I grew up with
King Kong King Kong is something that's
special to me when I was a kid I
rewatched King Kong vs. Godzilla on VHS
tape over and over and over and despite
how terrible it really was I loved it
and I actually enjoyed Peter Jackson's
King Kong and of course the original and
even the Jeff Bridges King Kong in the
70s there's a trend lately in Hollywood
and that trend is to pluck a director
from indie obscurity and give them a
gigantic franchise they did it with Marc
Webb after 500 days of summer they said
here have amazing spider-man see how
that goes
they did it with Gareth Edwards after
monsters they said here have Godzilla
see how that goes they did it with Colin
Trevorrow after safety not guaranteed
they said here have Jurassic world let's
see what happened and once again the
director of the kings of summer a pretty
good independent movie is now helming
Kong Skull Island I don't know why
they're doing this but with this film I
think it shows there are some really
impressive sequences in this movie there
are some very fun action sequences in
this movie when King Kong punches things
it's entertaining it's a big gigantic
monster having fights with other big
gigantic monsters and it looks cool and
that's about the best this movie has to
offer the characters that populate this
film are Hollow and boring bland shells
of human beings that are just expendable
nothings that are thrown into a script
so that Kong can probably kill them and
we won't care but we'll have fun because
the third act is action-packed rogue one
did the very same thing they populated a
film with a bunch of references to other
things that we know and like that we've
seen before that make us excited to get
our inner fanboy or fangirl squealing
and
have some bland who gives a shit
characters involved with it so that
eventually in the third act they can
have a whole bunch of really impressive
sequences and you leave on a high note
thinking well that was a good movie with
this film I'm not taking the bait
Thomson Hilton's character is met in a
bar he has a very poorly edited sequence
where he takes some guys out with a pool
stick and I guess he's just kind of a
cool badass guy who knows how to track
animals and cents so they asked him to
go to this island and that's that's his
character he has one scene where he has
a heart-to-heart with brie Larson where
he mentions something that happened once
in his past and that's really all it is
it's one of those character scenes at a
we just realized Tom Hiddleston is
really nothing in this movie and the
actor is probably telling us quite a bit
that he really needs some character we
really need to get Hiddleston off our
back
alright we're right in the scene where
he says something happened to him once
there you go there he has a character
now real arson in the film plays a
photographer that's her character she
takes pictures of things there's one
moment where samuel l.jackson looks
through her Foreman goes whoa you were
in the shit alright yeah good for you
that's her character she's seen a lot
and she's taken photos of all of it
besides that she's bland as hell there
are two interesting characters in this
movie samuel l.jackson character and
john t Reilly's character john c reilly
has been on this island for quite some
time and you learn a lot about his
backstory he actually has a history and
all of it is just him walking around in
a circle telling us what happened to him
it's just a gigantic exposition scene
where he literally takes the characters
to this big room with paintings and
hieroglyphics and sculptures of things
so that he can tell everyone his history
in the history of this island and
Jackson's character has a vendetta early
on in the movie he has a moment in a
phone booth where he gets some orders
and he gets all excited he gets giddy
because he gets to go out and do
something you can tell that as a
character he doesn't feel alive unless
he is at war or has some orders so he
makes up this big Vendetta which I won't
get into spoilers for you this opposite
movie isn't out yet but his character it
was intriguing there was something to
him everyone else in the movie is just
an attractive person who can run in slow
motion
throw some grenade
and that's about it Toby Kebbell has a
son at home who he writes letters to I
guess there was something there but for
the most part all the characters in this
movie are a major disappointment
they're just expendable bodies for Kong
or other monsters to play around with
let's talk about the setting Skull
Island I was so excited to see what they
could do with this location I was so
ready to see what they could do with
such a cool environment let me put it to
you this way do you remember when we
heard that the Jungle Book was going to
be shot entirely in a studio and
everyone lost their minds and we were
all worried it was going to look really
bad and not realistic and was going to
look like a green screen mess and then
it ended up looking amazing Skull Island
is that film that I was afraid that
jungle book was going to be despite the
fact that they actually shot a lot of
this movie on real locations there are
entire sequences that just look like
they were shot in a green room in the
third act of the movie there's a
sequence where Tom Hiddleston and brie
Larson are standing in front of King
Kong in between him and samuel l.jackson
and this entire scene looks like one of
the Star Wars prequels the worst green
screen in the Star Wars prequels I could
not believe what I was looking at the 3d
also really did not help it's very very
distracting and it feels out of place
the film is often trying to be a 1970s
war film with a lot of CCR music and it
just doesn't mesh with this world that
they're also trying to build with King
Kong and since all the characters are so
horrific aliy bland I just really did
not give a shit about anyone also let's
talk about the directing and the editing
it's rather bad it's distractingly bad
all the sequences where King Kong is
beating things up it's a big epic wide
shot and it goes for a long time and
it's really entertaining whenever it
goes to just character scenes there's a
very abrasive almost visually aggressive
way that this film is edited together
and it got on my nerves very fast and I
was very sad to actually be kind of
annoyed with the way the film was cut
together tonally the film is completely
off as well
the attempts at humor fall flat and
almost all respects john c reilly has a
couple good laughs as well as samuel
l.jackson and beyond that it's
basically because those two actors are
so likeable it is funny it's not really
the script it's just them bringing their
own charisma to some very stilted
dialogue then we'll be sequences where
brie Larson is trying to connect with
Kong emotionally and it feels so out of
left field then all of a sudden there's
a lot of slow fast moe that reminded me
of the way Michael Bay directs action
I'm not exaggerating this film was a
major disappointment for me I didn't
like a single character in the movie
Kong has one really awesome fight scene
and beyond that it felt like an attempt
to ape no pun intended the Marvel
routine
there's even an after credit scene it
all just feels like a big attempt to try
to recreate the Marvel success route and
I am not buying it I'm going to give
Kong Skull Island a c-minus I'm sorry to
disappoint you guys you might enjoy this
film if you just want to see Kong punch
some things and you don't give a shit
about characterization or anything else
like that but if you were hoping for
some engaging characters along with Kong
punching things I don't think this is
your film guys thank you so much as
always for watching and as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my knives
[Applause]
[Music]